Donald Trump isn't the only person on
the campaign trail having troubles with
facts Trump Hillary Clinton and they're
running mates are keeping fact-checkers
busy all of the comments you're about to
hear are not true hillary wants to
abolish essentially abolish the Second
Amendment we have the most dynamic
productive workforce in the world bar
none she actually said out loud we are
going to raise taxes on the middle class
the thing that has amazed me is the the
depth of his trash talking of Latinos
saying that all Mexicans are rapists and
going after you know Latino immigrants
the obama-clinton war on coal has caused
Michigan over 50,000 jobs director Comey
said that my answers were truthful and
what I've said is consistent with what I
have told the American people that there
were decisions discussed and made to
classify retro actively certain of the
emails joining us now to separate fact
from fiction this election season as
PolitiFact founding editor his name is
Bill Adair he's also a Duke journalism
professor and he joins us from good ol
raleigh north carolina that's Charlie
Rose country hello good to see you bill
Adair it is good morning Gail so you
just heard the montage that we put
together of untruths and before we get
into specifics how does how does this
season compared to political seasons in
the past in terms of factually
challenged statements if you will well
it's been crazy busy for us absolute
fact there's the magnitude of the claims
and particularly the magnitude of the
falsehoods is really remarkable and I
think it just reflects how the media has
changed and there's so many more ways
now that candidates can get their
messages out without the filter of the
news media and that allows them to say
things that often aren't true Donald
Trump says he would be that he was being
sarcastic with his latest comment does
that exempt him from the factor fiction
test I'll tell you we we had originally
rated his claim pants on fire which is
our lowest rating the rating
we use for falsehoods that are not just
false but ridiculously false but it's
you know it's really remarkable here's a
here's a talking point that he's been
using for several days now he doubled
down on it yesterday as you noted in the
interview with Hugh Hewitt and and now
he claims he was being sarcastic it's
just truly remarkable I think we need a
new rating on our truth-o-meter for this
you're talking about the claim obviously
that that he had that Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton founded Isis are John
Dickerson says its statements like that
that Trump is sort of baiting these fact
checkers like you to keep the
conversation going is that what he's
doing well I think it is remarkable that
he wants to keep the conversation going
particularly when I can't imagine that
any communications strategist would say
it makes sense I mean he is getting fact
checkers and other journalists to point
out again and again that he's that his
statements are false and it just makes
no it doesn't make a lot of sense is
abating fact checkers you know I think
there's definitely he likes baiting
everybody but build I mean is there some
point to the notion that the checking
system needs to be refined at all when
somebody says the sky is not blue I mean
is there is there a need to fact check
that well we're we're selective in what
we fetch a cat PolitiFact's so we will
check claims where we think people will
wonder really is that true and I think
with the with the claim that President
Obama and Hillary Clinton founded Isis I
think it's legitimate you know people
will hear that and wonder really what
role did they play and that's what we
did at PolitiFact we looked into it we
found that Isis was actually founded in
two thousand four so four years before
Barack Obama was elected and those are
the kind of things we fact check so it's
not like we're social scientists we're
journalists and we're trying to satisfy
our our readers and viewers curiosity
Hillary Clinton obviously is not immune
right now a recent poll fifty-nine
percent of people say that Hillary
Clinton is dis
how does she stand up against the
fact-checking and that percentage as
well yeah you know it's interesting her
percentage of false and pants on fire
ratings is about the same as other
American politicians I think it's
thirteen percent by contrast Trump is at
fifty-five percent but i think what what
has happened with Secretary Clinton is
that people remember the big ones and so
the statement with co me that you played
earlier you know there was one where she
repeated something she had said before
that the fact checkers had said was
false and people remember those big
moments philadel good luck Keeping Up
with an extra three months thank you for
going to be busy thank you very much for
your time we are